Kilocclaw destroys OpenClaw. Kilo Claw
just changed the AI agent game forever.
OpenClaw has over 210,000 GitHub stars,
but setting it up, total nightmare. Kilo
Claw fixes all of that in under 60
seconds. And today, I'm going to show
you exactly how it works, why it
matters, and what [music] this means for
running real AI agents in your business.
Now, before we get into it, I want to
ask you something. Have you ever tried
to set up a self-hosted AI agent? You
download it, then you need Docker, then
something crashes, then there's a
dependency error, then you need to
update something, then it crashes
[music] again. Hours gone, nothing
working. That is the OpenClaw experience
for a lot of people. But here's what's
wild. OpenClaw itself is actually
incredible. It's one of the most
powerful open-source AI agent runtimes
ever built. Over 210,000 GitHub stars.
That's not a small project. That's one
of the most popular AI tools on the
planet. So, why are people still
struggling with it? Because setting it
up is hard. Keeping it running is hard.
Scaling it is hard. And that's exactly
the problem Kilocclaw was built to
solve. Hey, if we haven't met already,
I'm the digital avatar of Julian Goldie,
CEO of SEO agency Goldie Agency. Whilst
he's helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every comment, so make sure you comment
below. Let's break this all down. First,
let me tell you what OpenClaw actually
is because if you don't know, you need
to. OpenClaw is a selfhosted autonomous
AI agent. Think of it like having a
robot that can browse the web, manage
files, run tools, remember past
conversations, and connect to chat
platforms like Telegram and Discord.
It's built on a four-layer architecture.
Layer one, the gateway. This is how it
connects to the outside world, other
tools, other platforms, APIs. Layer two,
the reasoning engine. This is where the
AI thinks. It decides what to do next,
which tool to use, how to respond. Layer
three, the memory layer. This is huge.
Openclaw has persistent memory. It
remembers things across sessions. You
don't have to repeat yourself every
single time you start a new
conversation. Layer four, the execution
layer. This is where it actually does
things. Run a search, open a browser,
create a file, send a message, put all
four together, and you have a fully
autonomous AI agent that can do real
work. And it just got even better. In
early March 2026, OpenClaw dropped a
massive update, real-time streaming,
adaptive thinking, threadbound memory,
over 40 security fixes to make it
production ready. They also added an iOS
app alpha, Grock, search integration,
and enhanced agent UI, and external
secrets management for security. This is
not some side project. This is serious
AI infrastructure. But here's the
problem. All of this power is locked
behind a wall of complexity for most
people. You have to self-host it. That
means servers, Docker containers, manual
updates, debugging crashes at 2 a.m.
Most business owners don't want to do
that and they shouldn't have to. So,
let's talk about Kilocclaw. Now, if you
want to learn how to set up AI
automation workflows like this one for
your own business, join the AI profit
boardroom. It's the best place to scale
your business, get more leads, and save
hundreds of hours with AI automation.
The link is in the comment and
description. We've got the tools, the
templates, and the community to help you
implement this stuff fast. Kilocclaw is
a fully managed hosted version of
OpenClaw. One click under 60 seconds.
Your agent is live. No Docker, no server
setup, no manual configuration. You just
go in, hit deploy, and it runs.
Kilocclaw provisions your OpenClaw
instance on Fly.io, which is a solid
production grade infrastructure
platform, and then it handles everything
on top of that. Automatic restarts if
something crashes, monitoring. So you
know what's happening. Instant model
switching without touching a single line
of code. You want to switch from one AI
model to another. Click done. No
rebuilding. No reconfiguring. And here
is the part that really matters for
businesses. Kilocclaw gives you access
to over 500 AI models through something
called Kylo Gateway. 500 models. That
means you can pick the best model for
each job. Need fast responses? Use a
lightweight model? Need deep reasoning
for a complex task? Swap to something
more powerful. And you don't have to
redeploy anything. You just switch. For
the AI profit boardroom, this is exactly
the kind of setup we'd use to run AI
automation at scale. Imagine having an
agent that connects to your Telegram
community, answers member questions,
handles on boarding, manages follow-ups,
all running 24/7 without you touching
it. That's what Kilo Claw makes
possible. Now, let me talk about the
enterprise features because this is
where Kilocclaw really separates itself
from self-hosted OpenClaw. Single sign
on. So if you have a team, everyone logs
in securely through a central system. No
shared passwords, proper access control,
cron jobs. You can schedule your AI
agents to run at specific times. Send a
daily report. Run a weekly analysis.
Trigger an automation at exactly 9:00
a.m. every Monday. All automated or
hands-off multiplatform support. Your
OpenClaw agent can connect to Telegram,
Discord, other platforms. And Kilocclaw
manages all of those connections without
you having to wire them up manually. And
because it's hosted, you never have to
think about updates. When OpenClaw
pushes a new version, like those 40 plus
security fixes, Kilocclaw handles it.
You don't have to pull new code, rebuild
containers, or pray that nothing breaks.
For context, if you're running this
yourself on a VPS or a home server,
every single update is a risk. One bad
config and your agent goes offline. With
Kiloclaw, that's not your problem. Let
me show you how this would actually work
for a real business use case. Say you're
running the AI profit boardroom. You
want an AI agent that does the following
things. One, it monitors your Telegram
channel 247 and answers common member
questions about AI automation. Two,
every morning at 8:00 a.m., it searches
the web for the top three AI news
stories and posts a summary to the
community. Three, when a new member
joins, it sends a personalized welcome
message, shares the getting started
guide, and checks in with them 3 days
later. Four, it keeps memory of every
interaction, so it knows what each
member has already been told. Without
Kylo Claw, setting this up would take
days. You'd need to host OpenClaw
yourself, set up Docker, configure web
hooks, write the Chron jobs, connect the
Telegram API, and then maintain all of
it. With KiloClaw, you deploy your
instance in 60 seconds, configure your
integrations through the dashboard, set
your Chron jobs with a few clicks, and
connect Telegram in the platform UI.
That's it. your agent is running and you
didn't write a single line of
infrastructure code. That's the
difference. Let me talk about why this
timing matters. Open Claw just hit a
massive milestone with the March 2026
update. The real-time streaming update
means your agent responds as it thinks,
not just at the end. Users get a much
more natural responsive experience.
Instead of waiting 5 seconds for a full
reply, they see it being written out in
real time. Adaptive thinking means the
agent adjusts how deeply it reasons
based on the complexity of the task.
Simple question, fast answer, complex
task. It thinks harder and longer. This
saves tokens and compute costs without
sacrificing quality. Threadbound memory
is one of the most underrated features.
It ties memory to specific conversation
threads. So if you're running multiple
channels or use cases, your agent
doesn't mix up context between them. It
knows what happened in channel A and
what happened in channel B separately.
And the 40 plus security fixes make this
production ready. This isn't a toy
anymore. Businesses can actually deploy
this with confidence. Kilocclaw takes
all of these updates and packages them
in a way that any business can use. You
don't need a DevOps engineer. You don't
need to understand containers. You just
need a business problem and an internet
connection. Now, here's the open
question I want to leave you with. As AI
agents get more powerful, the barrier
isn't the technology anymore. OpenClaw
proves that the technology is
incredible. The barrier is deployment,
maintenance, and integration. Whoever
solves that best wins. Kilo Claw is
making a strong argument that the future
of AI agents is managed hosted
platforms, not self-hosted setups that
only engineers can run. And if that's
true, then businesses that get on this
now are going to have a massive head
start. Think about what it means to have
an AI agent that never sleeps, connects
to every platform your customers use,
remembers every interaction, and runs on
500 different models depending on what
the job needs. That's not the future.
That's available right now. Now, if you
want to dive even deeper into AI
automation, I've got something special
for you. I run a community called the AI
Profit Boardroom. The best place to
scale your business, get more customers,
and save hundreds with AI automation.
Learn how to save time and automate your
business with AI tools like Kilocclaw.
And if you want the full process, SOPs,
and 100 plus AI use cases like this one,
join the AI success lab. You'll get all
the video notes from there, plus access
to our community of 45,000 members who
are crushing it with AI. The link is in
the comments and description.